second débat dans ce sens publiques
consacrées à la culture du compromis
politique peut-elle gagner les rangs de
l'assemblée des partis d'opposition et
de l'exécutif pour y arriver faudrait
s'inspirer de nos voisins européens
sandra ça car
la france n'est pas habituée aux
alliance gouvernementale
mais en europe elles sont beaucoup plus
courante voire nécessaire 19 pays sur 27
sont gouvernés par des alliances entre
partis la raison est simple hormis au
royaume uni et en france les élections
législatives se font au scrutin
proportionnel
il n'y a donc jamais de majorité absolue
pour un parti en allemagne le bundestag
vit au rythme des accords entre partis
le parti social démocrate allemande olaf
scholz est uni avec les verts et les
libéraux pour obtenir la majorité
absolue
les collisions allemandes sont plus
solide parce que les gens sérieux qui
conclut contre qui s'engagent sur un
contrat ça prend des semaines des mois
en italie c'est l'union nationale autour
de mario draghi toutes les grandes
formations sauf le très droitier
fratelli d'italia soutiennent le premier
ministre de la gauche radicale du
mouvement 5 étoiles à la ligue d'extrême
droite vous allez où là aussi il ya eu
des tentatives de contrat de coalition
en fête se tient généralement pas très
longtemps et à la première grosse
difficulté la collection ses crocs en
espagne pays marqué par le bipartisme
l'émergence de nouvelles forces
politiques obligent les deux grands
partis traditionnels à s'allier le
gouvernement est constitué d'une
coalition de centre gauche entre le
parti socialiste ouvrier espagnol le
parti des socialistes de catalogne et
l'alliance unie das podemos mais cette
coalition reste fragile avec une
majorité relative au parlement
nécessitant l'aide d'autres forces
politiques pour l'adoption des lois en
belgique cette partie saute au pouvoir
et dans les pays scandinaves aussi les
alliances sont nécessaires au danemark
en suède et en norvège
ce sont même des coalition minoritaire
qui sont au pouvoir soutenus par des
partis rester hors de l'exécutif notre
classe politique peut-elle apprendre
l'art du compromis et de la coalition
halal thème de notre débat et je vous
présente
invités et les demi-heures de la croix
bonsoir ça bienvenue vous êtes
professeur à la sorbonne universités
spécialiste de l'allemagne contemporaine
chercheuse au ciri ses auteurs avec
andreas vishing deux ennemis
héréditaires un dialogue franco-allemand
publié aux éditions fayard marc lazar
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur du centre d'histoire de
sciences po auteur de l'histoire du
parti communiste français aux presses
universitaires de france et aussi les
socialistes européens et l'état publié
aux éditions de l'aube patrick martin
geniez bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po paris
spécialiste des questions européennes
votre livre vers une sixième république
ou comment refonder la démocratie
française c'est aux éditions studyrama
et lætitia kluba éditorialiste politique
est resté à mes côtés une petite
normalement dans ce débat on essaye de
prendre le plus de recul possible mais
là on est un peu rattrapé par
l'actualité et donc l'événement
politique du jour l'élection donc de la
nouvelle présidente de l'assemblée
nationale il ya elles broutent iv qui
était la candidate d'ensemble c'était
prévu elles l'emportent et les deux
maires de la croatie il ya déjà un
message c'est j'aurais voulu ne pas
commencer par là mais sauf que c'est la
première fois qu'une femme est élue au
perchoir mais oui la france se rattrape
un petit peu le retard vu vu du l'autre
côté du rhin
la france a mis beaucoup de temps à osé
confier des responsabilités à des femmes
et lorsqu'il faisait pas de borne a été
choisi comme chef de gouvernement ça a
été remarquée
on regarde toujours le président de la
république un but de l'autre côté on
s'étonne presque qu'il vient parlement
puisque le contraste est extrêmement
fort en les deux interfaces de
constitution et l'organisation du pays
non seulement l'allemagne est un état
fédéral
donc on regarde en allemagne on croit
toujours qu'on regarde le niveau fédéral
madame merkel a l'époque monsieur
scholtes en allemagne regarde le niveau
régional d'abord c'est ça qui intéresse
les gens parce que c'est là que les
choses se décident pour eux et puis
quand il regarde la france il regarde le
président de la république sait c'est un
effet loupe de notre vème république qui
dans sa pratique
accorde moins de place au parlement qu
en allemagne et je crois que les
français se trompent toujours lorsqu'il
met en équivalence le chancelier et le
président de la république puisque l'un
est le chef de gouvernement l'autre et
chef de l'état et puis la position n'est
pas du tout la même le chef de
gouvernement allemand le chancelier il
doit trouver une coalition et l'appui du
parlement dans ce contexte de majorité
relative marc lazar ya une bonne pouvait
avoir un rôle encore plus important est
ce qu'il ya on est vraiment dans le
comparatif européen est ce qu'il ya un
rôle comme sa politique fort chez les
présidents d'assemblée chez nous chez
nos voisins ben oui un peu comme vous
savez je m'intéresse à l'italie oui moi
sûr puisque c'est un régime
parlementaire si un bicaméralisme
intégral c'est-à-dire que les italiens
élise au suffrage universel leurs
sénateurs et leurs députés et les deux
assemblées ont les mêmes pouvoirs c'est
à dire que c'est absolument fondamental
le rôle de des deux chambres et c'est
aussi très fondamentale le rôle
justement des présidences de chambre
parce que ça va être la culture de la
médiation à propos de femmes je remarque
que l'italie a déjà eu deux femmes qui
ont été aux présidentes des chambres une
communiste tenez vous bien et
communistes de plus en plus modérée mais
qui était l'ancienne épouse du grand
dirigeant du parti communiste italien
palmiro togliatti elle s'appelait o'neal
d'oeil aux ti et l'autre femme a été et
rennes previti c'est à dire une
représentante de la ligue en 1994 alors
pourquoi je développe cette exemple
parce que ces deux partis qui étaient
considérés à une certaine époque comme
des partis anti-système que ça soit le
parti communiste que ce soit la ligue du
nord à l'époque est la ligue du nord en
1994 était très dur le parti communiste
italien s'était assagi et et avait
progressivement intégrer les valeurs
démocratiques et respecter tout à fait
les règles mais dans les deux cas le
fait d'occuper cette fonction fait que
cette personne prend les responsabilités
à ses capacités de médiation se
transforme elle même éventuellement est
justement est un vecteur des médiations
et de la culture du compromis ces deux
logiques différentes qui est qui et 2 et
d'atténuation la perception par
l'opinion que ce sont des extrêmes ça
rejoint le débat qu'on avait dans notre
première partie d'émission mais c'est
d'accéder à ces a bien sûr
il n'y a pas que le cas italien il ya
d'autres car par exemple le cas
israélien tout à fait intéressant c'est
à dire que quand on a des sociétés très
divisée
dans la société avec des forces
politiques qui s'affrontent les chambres
les assemblées parlementaires c'est ce
qu'on appelle en science politique la
démocratie consociative font que
justement la résolution de ces conflits
pour éviter que ça explose justement
passe par l'intermédiaire des chambres
et par les pratiques parlementaires qui
transforme justement les forces les plus
en 10 systèmes plus ou moins plus ou
moins parfois par opportunisme
incontestablement parce que les gens
voient le rester au pouvoir parlons
clairement mais parfois aussi par
l'assimilation justement des règles
démocratiques et la compréhension que ce
qui leur paraissait simple à
l'opposition devient beaucoup plus
compliqué quand on est en situation de
responsabiliser a bien fait pour la
démocratie et non pas un danger mais à
mon sens oui et je crois qu'on assiste
trop dans les situations de crise
démocratique que nous connaissons en
europe sur les faiblesses des
démocraties qui sont réelles on sait
qu'il ya une désaffection très
importante des opinions on sait qu'il y
à un roger de la classe politique le
rejet des élites qui a des tendances
justement à l'acceptation de la violence
même mais et du coup on dit nos
démocraties sont faibles et je crois
qu'on ne prend pas assez en
considération la force des institutions
y compris dans le cas italien moi ça
m'amuse c'est ce que j'appelle la force
d'une démocratie faible c'est à dire
qu'elle est faible effectivement mais
lâché capacité d'absorption des charges
protestataires en france on a beaucoup
de mal à l'accepter pour des raisons sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir patrick
martin geniez ça va être intéressant je
reviens à ce rôle de
il ya une banque privée présidente de
l'assemblée nationale avec la nouvelle
donne politique
avec ce jeu d'alliances qui vont sans
doute se faire au cas par cas texte par
texte elle va avoir un rôle presque
central presque oui plus important que
je ne sais pas le ministre des relations
avec le parlement enfin elle va elle va
être à la manoeuvre pas dit pas de mal
du ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement parce que j'ai vu ce matin
avec les sénateurs et justement il
entretenait beaucoup de dialogues avec
dessinateur ça c'est drôle parce qu'il
lui avait été reproché une sorte de
l'éloignement de du sénat et de
l'assemblée non mais ça va renforcer les
liens naturellement entre le
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale et le
damier lebron peavey qui va avoir un
rôle véritablement centrale dès lors
qu'on a un appartement qui est éparpillé
avec des députés extremis d'un côté de
l'extrême droite 89 députés plus des
gens de gauche qui ne vont pas vous et
cette fameuse nul est bien aidé à d'ores
et déjà éclaté la cohérence n'existe
plus chacun roule à reconstituer son
groupe politique et ce matin précisément
j'en parlais avec les collègues du sénat
disait ce sera sans doute des non pas
des alliances mais des accords projet
par projet y compris à l'assemblée
nationale et c'est en cela que le rôle
de la présidente de l'assemblée
nationale sera essentielle pour trouver
on va dire d un modus vivendi sur la
façon de décider de se concerter par
exemple il est demandé à ce que le
gouvernement vient de plus en amont pour
discuter de ses projets de loi de ses
propositions parce que il est fort à
craindre que si le gouvernement ne
change pas de ligne politique ou n'est
pas après à la négociation beaucoup de
projets seront en effet repoussé toc là
et alors je voudrais une chose c'est
qu'en france on à l'été nous ne sommes
pas habitués à un gouvernement de
coalition vous l'avais dit en allemagne
vous avez vu entre l'élection à la
victoire des sociaux-démocrates la
désignation de la chose comme chancelier
il s'est passé deux mois il a fallu
négocier un contrat de gouvernement
comme un contrat de copropriété et rien
ne se décide si on n'a pas couché sur le
papier en italie c'est des coalitions
peut être un peu plus faible vous aviez
la faiblesse mais aussi la force de
l'italie le gouvernement du gp compte et
sauf erreur de ma réparé a quand même
duré trois ans
comptez 1 et 2 donc il a duré trois ans
ce qui fait lorsqu'on dit que la
l'italie est un pays faible non il est
capable de s'adapter enfin on a en
espagne c'est vraiment je crois
l'exemple que nous allons devoir suivre
un gouvernement dirigé par chanceuse pas
don pedro sanchez qui est socialiste
allez hop au demos qui est lui même
minoritaire avec sa coalition il détient
je crois que 155 députés sur les 350 et
donc il est constamment obligés de
négocier des subventions à la catalogne
également le fait d'avoir permis aux
prisonniers donc politique va dire de
catalogne d'être exempté d'être voilà et
et des subventions même au pays basque
et aux indépendantistes du pays basque
donc ça va des accords au cas par cas et
je crois qu'il ya une grande beaucoup de
choses à apprendre la part de la
première ministre et de la présidente de
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui alors
on va faire un focus tout de suite sur
l'allemagne je propose à à quand un
calme et de nous rejoindre bonsoir
quentin le fait de proposer des
coalitions en allemagne c'est la norme
tout simplement depuis 1949 oui je crois
qu'à une exception 1960 1961 mais
effectivement c'est la norme depuis 1949
à l'image effectivement de ce qui se
passe en ce moment en allemagne cette
coalition qui rassemble depuis décembre
dernier les sociaux démocrates emmenés
par olaf scholz que vous voyez à l'image
en ce moment même la coalition s'est
fait avec les verts et les libéraux les
trois parties ont signé un accord de
gouvernement coalition sphère traque
c'était début décembre 2021 soit un peu
plus de deux mois après les élections
législatives organisées fin septembre
2021 est assez court pour les
observateurs 1-2 - plus de deux mois
comme ça on a eu effectivement le double
parfois en allemagne regarder les
chiffres de ces élections législatives
on voit que les sociaux démocrates du
spd en rouge ont fait le meilleur score
avec 25% des voix le poste de chancelier
l'or est revenu ils se sont alliés avec
les écologistes arrivés troisièmes et
les libéraux en jaune arrivé quatrième
une alliance à trois qui est une
première l'hiver dernier le signe aussi
que les principaux partis un lad cdos cs
ou et le spd qui sont d'habitude les
grands partis qui forment comme ça les
coalitions ils sont affaiblis ils ont
besoin de deux alliés pour pouvoir
gouverner des ans m comment se passe
justement les négociations pour aboutir
pour trouver cette coalition on l'a lu
dans un article très récent je vous
conseille de thomas videur a dans le
monde juste après les élections
législatives des discussions
exploratoires sont organisés entre les
principaux dirigeants des partis ensuite
il négocie l'acolyte soundsphere trag
cet accord de coalition cela a peu
mobilisé plusieurs centaines de
personnes dans parfois 22 comités
différents écoutez paul maurice il est
chercheur à l'ifri
sur tous les partis arrivés troisièmes
et quatrièmes les verts et les libéraux
qui ont d'abord négocier entre eux pour
savoir s'ils pouvaient être d'accord sur
un programme de gouvernement pas ce sont
les partis opposés politiquement avec
beaucoup de divergences et ensuite ils
se sont prononcés pour une coalition
avec tel ou tel parti alors il y avait
peu de suspense on pensait que c'était
sûrement avec les sociaux démocrates
mais il aurait aussi pu se prononcer
pour les chrétiens démocrates qui sont
arrivés deuxièmes et donc on va le voir
ils ont signé comme cela un accord assez
précis de 144 pages qui a été validé par
les formations politiques en congrès
extraordinaire
donc on le voit il est signé comme cela
devant la presse avec les trois rubans
de couleur différente de cet alliage
nouveau écouter à nouveau paul maurice
l'accord de coalition si une feuille de
route il n'engage pas légalement les
parties à le respecter on le voit pour
certaines mesures comme par exemple la
fin du charbon pour la production
d'électricité cette mesure est remise en
cause avec l'augmentation des prix
d'énergie suite à la guerre en ukraine
mais c'est quand même une feuille de
route hockey les parties doivent
s'attacher le contrat de coalition
définit également quels ministères
échoira à quel parti et ensuite les
parties désigne en interne la
personnalité qui va diriger le ministère
donc ça fait aussi partie d'une
répartition voilà cette tradition ac est
à l'opposé de ce que nous on connaît
avec la vème république
c'est lié au fait que depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale l'allemagne a
cherché
éviter une trop grande concentration des
pouvoirs c'est ce qui explique aussi le
système fédéral en allemagne et le
chancelier n'est donc jamais vraiment là
pour diriger une coalition plutôt pour
tenter de construire des compromis entre
les différents courants qui la composent
merci quentin et les deux maires de la
croatie si on se projette si on prend
les résultats des is la team en france
le
ensemble c'est à dire la majorité
présentielle ses 42 % des sièges en
allemagne est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé
cerveau est ce que je veux dire c'est un
score très fort pour pour créer une
coalition il serait en position de force
pour mener une coalition alors c'est
arrivé dans le passé il ya eu une fois
où la télé ou en 1957 avait la majorité
absolue c'était l'époque de radio naouar
mais sinon dans la grande époque des
grands partis populaires comme on le
disait c'était soit l'axé du but contre
conservatrice soit le spd social
démocrate qui avait 40% des voix et qui
avait juste besoin de l'appoint où je
vais dans un point qui étaient en
général le petit parti libéral équipe à
s'excuser une fois d'à côté une fois de
l'autre après les verts sont entrés au
parlement est progressivement donc
l'extrême gauche un mobile inc et puis
le l'extrême droite populiste la fd ce
que je voudrais dire sur cet excellent
court tous ravis en plus d'entendre un
peu de mots d'allemand faisant de moins
en moins de mode allemand je pense qu'il
ya des choses qui sont importantes a
ajouté notamment le fait que la
coalition comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'est un état fédéral nous on regarde
toujours le niveau donc nationale sauf
que ces coalitions elles sont pratiquées
en allemagne dans chacun des länder qui
ont chacun un parlement donc il ya en
allemagne 17 parlements c'est est-ce que
c'est forcément la même veine donc je ne
sont pas à même assez pas forcément la
bonne solution a dit les allemands
votent tout le temps quasiment tout le
temps puisque les législatures ne sont
pas toujours en même temps donc il ya
des élections régionales régulièrement
qui obéissent à une logique régionale et
donc avec des résultats différents et de
la même façon qu'au niveau fédéral ce
sont les forces politiques la presse
elle qui arrive en tête qui a priori
amené à trouver une coalition avec
d'autres on pourrait aussi imaginer que
s'il n'y arrive pas ce soit toutes les
autres qu'ils fassent un gouvernement
sans s'ils se mettent d'accord et il y a
une très grande diversité de coalition
pendant très longtemps c'était comme je
le disais conservateur libéral ou
social-démocrate et béral aujourd'hui
vous avez absolument toutes les
compositions de couleur puisqu'on
utilise des couleurs pour qualifier les
parties et ses différentes coalitions
prouve que l'on est capable de
travailler les uns avec les autres alors
il ya un certain nombre de tabous
notamment le fait de travailler avec
l'afd le parti d'extrême droite allemand
dans aucun landes sauna cela n'a eu lieu
et l'autre tabou c'est d-link c'est à
dire l'extrême gauche ex communiste mais
ce tabou a été brisé déjà en allemagne
de l'est en inde et dans un des länder
dirigés précisément par un parent on va
dire un ancien communiste progressiste
alors ça c'est le premier point
important le deuxième point important
quand on compare et quand on essaie
d'imaginer
un transfert en france c'est que le
programme du gouvernement en allemagne
et on le connaît à la fin de ces
négociations et non pas avant puisque le
programme de gouvernement c'est cet
accord sur lequel on se sera mis
d'accord avec de nombreux experts ça a
été rappelé tout est vraiment regardé au
cordeau ça c'est aussi long c'est pour
ça c'était extrêmement long tout est
soupesé on essaie de trouver des frais
compromis c'est-à-dire que chacun réussi
à se profiler comme on dit c'est à dire
avant c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour lui est capable de céder
sur un autre point en ayant fixé des
lignes rouges et on se respecte ton
style très bien qu'il ya des zones où on
ne doit pas aller dans le passé parce
que cette coalition dirigée par aérosol
sel est tout à fait exemplaire elle et
elle a été extrêmement harmonieuse dans
le passé le contrat du gouvernement
était de coalition était souvent on
avait mis sous le tapis tout ce qui
gênait et on se retrouvait soit plus
petit commun dénominateur ce qui a
contribué d'ailleurs au manque
d'ambition de nombreux de plusieurs des
gouvernements dirigés par un gala merkel
parce que on se retrouvait au milieu sur
la lame de park et là il ya beaucoup
d'ambition et donc comme je le dis le
programme qui va être appliqué c'est ce
qui a été signé dans le contrat de
gouvernement donc ça oblige aussi c'est
un autre point dernier point important
qui est très différent dans la culture
politique non seulement c'est un pays
qui aime le compromis qui capable de
respecter le compromis mais aussi
commencé avant les élections pendant la
campagne que on va peut-être être amené
à travailler avec l'autre eh bien on est
quand même un peu moins désagréable non
trois c'est bien c'est bien ça donne une
campagne électorale un peu plus
civilisée si j'ose dire en tout cas pas
s'y fier
certains mais moi je crois pas mais marc
lazar le cas en italie
aux questions un peu plus générale sur
cette idée puisque c'est la xoom dispose
de culture politique de culture petit la
de la coalition du compromis une culture
politique j'imagine que c'est long à
construire et donc c'est peut-être long
à déconstruire aussi vous est ce que je
veux dire par rapport à ce qui se passe
en france évidemment si on prend si on
s'interroge sur cette difficulté à
réaliser des compromis en france on est
obligé d'essayer de trouver quelques
éléments d'explication il y en a une
sans doute dans la longue durée
incontestablement on est le pays de la
révolution française dans lequel très
rapidement l'idée même du compromis et
et est rejetée on est pour ou on est
content alors il faut être prudent avec
cela parce que sous la troisième
république ou sous la iv ème république
au sein des assemblées on savait faire
des coalitions mais il ya quand même cet
élément de culture politique très fort
en france révolutionnaire contre
révolutionnaire qui va marquer sur la
longue durée même si aujourd'hui
beaucoup des citoyens sont pas
conscients de cette situation mais ça je
crois que c'est un élément à prendre en
considération réellement dire qu'on
considère en france très souvent que le
compromis c'est la compromission bon ça
c'est le disions dans la très longue
durée après il ya eu l'expérience la
quatrième république et évidemment les
fondateurs de la 5e et en particulier
général de gaulle la dénonciation de la
république des partis ces gouvernements
instables ces coalitions et notamment
celle de la troisième force c'est-à-dire
cette coalition entre les centristes et
les socialistes pour résister à la
pression gaulliste d'un côté et
communistes de l'autre ont été très
critiqué y compris par ceux qui eux sont
les héritiers de ces formations par
exemple au sein du parti socialiste
lorsque françois mitterrand relance le
parti socialiste sur fond de parti
socialiste en 1971 c'est avec l'idée
qu'on ne peut plus s'allier avec les
centristes et qu'on doit faire une
alliance avec les communistes pour leur
prendre leur voix donc je pense que cet
héritage a beaucoup joué après il ya la
vème république juste c'est à dire
notamment à partir de référendum de 1962
l'élection au suffrage universel du
président de la république qui donne un
pouvoir considérable au président de la
république le système des partis qui va
se mettre progressivement en route et
notamment à partir des années 70 cette
bipolarisation même si après il ya
plusieurs formations entre la gauche et
la droite et qui aboutit à effectivement
une situation d'affrontement donc et pur
ajoutant un dernier élément c'est le
quinquennat mais je crois que ça a
changé beaucoup de choses donc c'est
vrai que du point de vue des acteurs
politiques on a beaucoup de mal à
accepter le compromis si on réfléchi et
je termine juste il ya un quelques
hommes qui ont essayé de jouer la carte
du compromis
centre-droit pour aller vite françois
bayroux centre gauche michel rocard et à
chaque fois dans leur camp ça n'a pas
été évident surtout pour michel rocard
d'essayer justement d'autant plus en
1988 il a dû pratiquer cela parce qu'il
avait là aussi on avait une situation de
majorité relative voilà on est un pays
qui a du mal à accepter de cette
situation du conte problème patrick
martin geniez il ya peut-être aussi une
une génération
de d'hommes et de femmes politiques
et puis on peut on peut moi je peux
maclure dedans de commentateurs
biberonné à la majorité absolue faire
que ça fait jeter a fait 35 ans qu'on
analyse la politique avec ce cette
grille de lecture et donc c'est un
enfant de la vème république et donc on
a toujours vu que cela mais je crois
quoi en fait il ya quelque chose qui ne
va pas parce qu'on reste sur le logiciel
de la vème république tout tourne autour
du président de la république peut-être
un jour en automne présidente de la
république mais tout autour du chef de
l'état c'est lui qui doit imprimer le
cours des événements politiques et si
vous avez entendu emmanuel macron à sa
décharge qu'il a dit c'est mon projet
qu'on va devoir appliquer avec quelques
amendements marginaux ici à droite à
gauche etc et c'est ça qui ne va pas
parce que sous la vème république hormis
les gouvernements de coalition je
rappellerai que le premier ministre la
première ministre c'est la chef du
gouvernement elle est là pour déterminer
et conduire la politique de la nation et
au fur et à mesure de ses 5e république
on a assisté à une présidentialisation
accrue du régime et donc un premier
ministre qui est devenu complètement
transparent pourquoi parce qu'il y avait
des majorités absolues d'orateur sarkozy
disait un collaborateur et certains même
un jour envisager de supprimer le
premier ministre est donc aujourd'hui on
voit répète une nouvelle forme une la
cuillère là l'aspect parlementaire de
ces 5e république c'était michel debré
qui au conseil d'état dit attention on
ne veut pas de régime présidentiel on
veut un régime parlementaire et c'est
cela aujourd'hui que l'on voit mais le
logiciel reste celui de la cinquième
tout doit tourner autour du président
est aujourd'hui en réalité tout le monde
doit apprendre à faire un nouveau pas
c'est nouveau c'est nouveau
effectivement qui dit compromis ne dit
pas nécessairement compromissions et
donc ça veut pas dire pour autant qu'on
va faire un gouvernement de coalition
car aujourd'hui le défi de la première
ministre s'est essayé essayé d'attirer à
elle une majorité cdci naturel des
personnalités est-ce qu'elle va attirer
des personnalités qui ne représenteront
qu'elle-même en réalité ou est ce
qu'elle va réussir à signer un contrat
de gouvernement notamment avec les
républicains vous avez vu monsieur
darmana le mezzé intérieur dire que
finalement il y avait beaucoup de points
en commun avec les républicains puisque
ce soit à peu près les seuls partis
politiques qui est capable d'assurer de
majorité absolue à ce gouvernement
laëtitia depuis le résultat de ces
législatives on a souvent brandi la
menace du retour à la ivème république
voilà l'instabilité des gouvernements
successifs une assemblée divisée vous
n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord avec les
comparaisons pourquoi non je crois que
nous sommes tous captifs d'une part de
la communication jusqu'au boutiste de la
france insoumise qui a vendu puisque
c'était du marketing politique jean-luc
mélenchon à matignon et ensuite la
cohabitation est aussi surpris c'est
vrai par le score du rassemblement
national or si on regarde un peu
froidement ce qui se passe ou en l
assemblée on l'a dit un bien sûr
emmanuel macron et il y avait deux
bornes ont une majorité relative mais
pas minable il reste 40 députés à
convaincre et comme la stratégie qui se
dessine est celle de la négociation
texte par texte on peut déjà comprendre
comment cela va se passer par exemple
avec ce nouveau groupe à l'assemblée
alors je lis ma fiche parce quils le nom
est difficilement se passer
mais un mauvais choix liberté
indépendance outre-mer territoire c'est
tout les non-inscrits qui se sont
regroupés il faut un groupe alors il y
aurait des macros compatible parmi eux
et puis aussi du côté de la gauche au
mob écologie les verts ou les
socialistes et bien sûr les tous dit la
réserve de voix des républicains
ce sur quoi
gérald darmanin d'un quasiment aucun
doute écoutez le sur rtl ce matin on
n'est pas d'accord sur tout avec les
verts lors des d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses je pense que par exemple sur la
sécurité ou sur l'immigration nous avons
une majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale pour donner davantage de
moyens de policiers et pour les mesures
que je vais proposer à la demande du
président de la république majorité
absolue ça ne vous a pas échappé donc
bien sûr qu'ils sont en train de draguer
comme on dit les airs alors il a même
développé il a dit sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la sécurité l'immigration
les impôts les finances publiques on est
d'accord et vous avez remarqué ce petit
appel du pied de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie sur la dette qui
est le sujet à traiter après la
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte donc on
a compris comment se positionner le
gouvernement mais je crois que nous ne
sommes pas du tout dans la quatrième
république avec un risque d'instabilité
insurmontable et d'ailleurs pour rappel
un petit rappel historique ce régime
avait quand même bien commencé c'était
général de gaulle qui avait libéré la
france et qui avait une assemblée
tripartite avec les trois forces là issu
de la résistance les sociaux-démocrates
et socialistes et les communistes et en
fait finalement cette 4è république est
et reste le régime le moins aimé le mal
aimé un peu en france pourquoi parce que
elle c'est fini dans le bourbier de la
guerre d'algérie de l'indépendance et
nous ne sommes pas là du tout thomas
l'exécutif reste confiant sur son
pouvoir de négociation évidemment il va
essayer de capter les petites têtes
d'affiché ça se transmet pas
immédiatement au vote mais quand même ça
peut permettre d'apaiser on va dire les
négociations et puis il y aura aussi une
des conséquences moins de loi à voter
parce que plus de discussions c'est
chiant de pouvoir d'achat ne devrait pas
poser grand complet et puis marc lazar
si on fait un peu d'histoire la
quatrième république on a beaucoup
réformer
la france était pas à l'arrêt les
historiens ont revisité beaucoup à
l'histoire de la 4ème république bien
sûr il ya l'instabilité parce que vous
l'avez rappelé ya aussi la guerre froide
qui fait tout exploser parce que le
système de ce qu'on appelle le
tripartisme explose le parti communiste
français qui nous rappelle il faut le
rappeler notamment aux jeunes étudiants
parce que quand on leur dit le parti
communiste français était le premier
parti politique en france il y en a un
étudiant un court qui m'a dit là vous
plaisantez
non mais c'est il ya un effort culturel
évidemment mais donc oui on revisite
parce que effectivement ça a été un
grand moment de développement économique
de la france une forte croissance un
certain nombre d' avantages sociaux qui
ont été faits notamment avec le
gouvernement de guy mollet à partir de
1956 enfin c'est un pays qui est le
trait des droits et le que vous avez
raison en 1957 était drôle il ya une
semaine il ya effectivement la guerre
d'algérie bon ça ça a été le drame delà
de la quatrième république mais c'est
vrai que les historiens ont tendance à
revisiter cette histoire de la 4ème
république en distinguant justement
cette fragilité du système politique
cette instabilité gouvernementale et les
réaliser les réalisations économiques et
sociales cela dit on est en train en un
peut-être ce soir de faire l'éloge de
ces coalitions il faut dire aussi qu'il
ya un revers ça a été très bien dit par
hélène c'est à dire que parfois ces
coalitions sont tellement hétérogènes
qu'on a du mal à prendre des décisions
qu'ont
bien sûr et comme vous l'avez dit vous
pourriez d'ailleurs rajouté un exemple
évidemment sur les questions d'énergie
je pense que manuel maquereau ou plus
exactement un porn va se faire un malin
plaisir de présenter son programme
nucléaire pour avoir le soutien des
communistes et faire éclater encore plus
la coalition de gauche parce que les
communistes se sont avec monsieur
roussel se sont prononcés en faveur de
sont toujours prononcés en faveur du
nucléaire pourrait même avoir les voix
du rassemblement national c'est
peut-être effectué en est d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant juste pour terminer là
dessus de voir comment les français se
comportent parce que d'un côté ils se
disent très satisfaits de cette
situation 71% et je pense que c'est la
marge de manoeuvre on n'arrête pas de
dire que c'est très difficile pour le
gouvernement et ça va l'être mais de
l'autre côté la situation est compliquée
pour tout l'est quasiment toutes les
autres formations politiques les
républicains sont divisés las nubes
aussi entre les différents vous l'avez
rappelé van wyk entre les différentes
composantes donc c'est compliqué le seul
parti qui est homogène célérité et c'est
le rassemblement national et en même
temps il ya une pression manifestement
des français pour des mois maintenant il
ya ça débrouillez vous le faites quelque
chose et donc les me semble-t-il les
formations qui resterait uniquement dans
une opposition résolue radical
risquerait peut-être de le payer et
d'ailleurs je remarque que beaucoup de
députés y compris france à sion 10 et
rassemblement national dit attention
s'il ya certaines dispositions qui nous
conviennent on l'évoquera parce que ils
ont senti le message des français le
pourcentage très important de
l'abstention et la manière de tissot
voter pour ceux qui ont voté je reste
sur cette question de culture politique
de la négociation je propose d'entendre
le président du sénat gérard larcher
était ce matin sur sur lci alors il dit
à un premier test qui approchent
évidemment le texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat et pour gérard larcher ça
commence mal nous découvrons dans les
échos ce qui va être notamment le texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat je téléphone à la
commission des finances du sénat remet
vous reçu un avant projet nom ou la
vraie méthode ce serait d'associer les
commissions des finances les commissions
des lois en fonction des textes et puis
de préparer un certain nombre de
propositions il va falloir une vraie
révolution culturelle de la part des gc
ca mais aussi de nous mêmes elle y met
ainsi nous mêmes il ya cette lucidité
j'espère qu'elle sera collective et les
deux maires de la croix quand j'ai
préparé cette émission en pensant
l'allemagne le site mais ils doivent
rigoler les allemands voyons qu il avait
demandé à une semaine pour essayer de
créer une coalition de shekels termes
d'actions ou d'actions
gouvernement d'action maire de mende
action alors ça dépend qui toute
l'allemagne n'est pas les yeux virer
longue rivés sur la sur la france
s'intéresse à la france il ya eu dans
les derniers temps juste avant la
présidentielle et puis avant les
résultats des législatives une vraie
inquiétude à la limite une plus grande
inquiétude qu qu'on pouvait la sentir en
france face à la montée des extrêmes qui
est toujours
obsession en allemagne et
la crainte d'une incapacité du président
une fois qu'il a été élu a vraiment
gouverner mais pour revenir sur la
culture politique parce que ça va
exactement dans ce sens
c'est toujours l'external question que
l'on a qui ai dû dire qu'est-ce qui est
la poule et qu'est-ce qu'il ' est-ce
qu'on a un comportement parce qu'on a
les institutions qui nous contraignent
avoir un comportement ou est ce que on a
les institutions de confrontation parce
que la culture politique qui serait
première favoriserait cela je crois que
l'exemple que nous avons aujourd'hui est
une contrainte de changement de pratique
ce que disait gérard larcher tout à fait
juste lit on a on a désappris ce qu'on
avait pu savoir faire sous la iv ème un
public qui était en effet de chercher
des compromis et de réfléchir de
s'appuyer beaucoup plus sur son parti qu
on le fait et ça je pense que le cas
allemand cas quand même eu connu dans le
xxème siècle une rupture absolument
massive montre que non seulement on peut
apprendre
de nouvelles pratiques et que ces
pratiques modèle les comportements mais
aussi comment dire d'une certaine façon
que les valeurs qui sont transformés
transporté vis-à-vis de l'extérieur sont
bien bien meilleur ou au positive parce
qu en allemagne c'est beaucoup plus
valorisant puisque l'on voit à la
télévision ces débats peut-être qu'en
france on va s'intéresser un petit peu
plus ce qui se passe dans les parlements
dans les deux champs c'est beaucoup plus
positif en allemagne de montrer que l'on
est capable d'avoir un discours qui
marque à la fois quelles sont les lignes
de la dalle de d'identité d'un parti
mais la capacité à avoir fait des
compromis alors et ça c'est un point
très intéressant pour l'extrême droite
en allemagne parce qu'ils ont la foi ils
sont confrontés à ce qu'ont connu les
verts qui était un peu radicaux dans la
fin des années 80 et qu'ils sont entrés
dans cette culture parlementaire
absolument parfaitement et en même temps
l'afd l'extrême droite allemande si elle
veut conserver son profit il faut
qu'elle reste dans le coup d essai d
ailleurs c'est un vrai défi aussi pour
le rassemblement national de marine le
pen c'est à force de
intégrer d'accepter le système est ce
qu'elle va garder ce qui faisait sa
singularité sur le paysage politique
dans le paysage politique français oui
je voulais simplement ajouté par rapport
à ce que vous disiez c'est qu'en france
seront parle beaucoup de l'assemblée
nationale mais cette nouvelle
configuration politique selon moi va
redonner un rôle accru au sénat vous
êtes au bon endroit pour le dire et
voilà donc c'est un message j'écoutais
des sénatrices ce matin j'étais très
très intéressés et qui disait ben nous
allons avoir un rôle important parce
qu'on va devoir sur proposés se
prononcer sur des projets projet par
projet l'assemblée nationale va sans
doute être divisé tantôt elle sera
d'accord et la navette parlementaire
avec le sénat va reprendre un rôle
d'autant plus important parce que vous
savez dans l'imaginaire des français le
sénat c'est la haute chambre qui bloque
certain nombre de projets or là ce n'a
pas toujours été le cas mais comme l'a
dit monsieur larcher je crois qu'il va
devoir également changé sa méthode et la
chambre haute avoir un rôle important
dans cette navette parlementaire dans le
fait de renforcer le compromis avec les
députés qui sont issus de cette nouvelle
législature marc lazar vous l'avez dit
vous vous connaissez très bien l'italie
vous êtes président de la school of
government de l'université luiss à rome
et si on fait là aussi un peu d'histoire
même si le souvenir des animaux souligne
s'estompe je l'imaginais en italie il ya
quand même ça dans l'explication du
système c'est hier que le souvenir de
l'homme fort et donc la laddh et des
pincettes où la crainte de l'homme fort
absolument elle m'a laissé un point
comparable avec l'allemagne bien
évidemment il ya eu vingt années de
fascisme le nazisme a été les plus
courts mais encore plus intense et
violent mais il ya vingt années de
fascisme et et des constituants en
1946-1947 puisque c'est en juin 46 ou le
2 juin 1946 que les italiens ont choisi
la république ont mis un an et demi pour
trouver une constitution non pas parce
qu'il travaille lentement mais parce
qu'il fallait mettre des forces
politiques ensemble et l'idée principale
c'est de réduire autant que possible
toute possibilité d'émergence d'une
dictature d'un homme ça c'est évident
d'où une relativisation du pouvoir
exécutif au profit du pouvoir législatif
alors beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous le
tibre un seul sous le pont est
effectivement progressivement les
pouvoirs exécutifs à essayer de
retrouver un peu plus de pouvoir en
particulier en utilisant la formule des
décrets lois mais oui c'est d'ailleurs
assez étonnant parce que d'un côté il ya
une surtout depuis une vingtaine
d'années une quête de l'homme un peu
fort en italie l'homme providentiel
bettino craxi pour les socialistes dans
les années de 80 silvio berlusconi est
évidemment matteo salvini maintenant
c'est une femme giorgia meloni membres
du parti frères d'italie qui est
d'extrême droite et en même temps il ya
une sorte de hantise du retour du duce
alors que nous sommes en 2022 et que les
italiens commémore et célèbre enfin
commémore plus exactement le centenaire
de la naissance du fasciste donc
effectivement on est dans cette tension
qui d'ailleurs est une sanction je crois
dans beaucoup de pays européens sans
doute pas l'allemagne c'est à dire étant
donné que la démocratie fonctionne mal
il ya une tendance mais les enquêtes
qu'on a au niveau européen montrent qu'à
peu près de 30 % des européens
voudraient des régimes un peu plus fort
est en même temps il ya cette inquiétude
dans les pays qui ont connu des
dictatures longue et terrible éprouvante
comme le fascisme en italie et le
nazisme de ne pas avoir ne pas se
retrouver dans cette situation où le
franquisme en espagne où le salazarisme
au portugal book ou la grèce des
colonels non pas liste est assez longue
c'est effectivement assez long elle est
une mère de la croix le chancelier
allemand si on le compare au prix en
français vous avez un parti répondu à la
question en rappelant la structure les
le pouvoir des länder il a moins de
pouvoir que le président français c'est
rennes a oui ah oui vraiment
c'est à dire ce n'est pas l'essai pas le
même pouvoir y leon c'est vous monsieur
qui savaient beaucoup mieux notre et
connaissait beaucoup mieux notre
constitution mais la politique étrangère
en allemagne et dans entre les mains du
chancelier et du mini sa phrase étrange
r c'est à dire que on n'a pas cette
particularité où le chef de l'état
français peut considérer que c'est son
domaine on avait pu le voir dans les
périodes de
la différence elle est vraiment dans le
fait que le chef du gouvernement
allemand le chancelier peut être
renversé du jour au lendemain s'il
n'obtient pas une majorité à l'assemblée
ça au bundestag 6 alors c'est pas comme
ça sans avoir rien prévu c'est à dire
que on l'a vu c'est arrivé une fois en
1982 1er octobre 82 lorsqu'elle me
schmitt a été renversé il y avait des
désaccords entre
libéraux et les sociaux démocrates et
libéraux se sont éloignés pour les
éléments des sociaux démocrates sur des
questions de finances publiques et il y
a eu par derrière des négociations avec
l'opposition
le chef de l'opposition et et helmut
kohl et il y a eu un vote de défiance
qui s'appelle un vote de défiance
constructive et j'écris pourquoi il est
constructif ont fait voter les députés
accordez-vous la confiance à ce
changement et ce gouvernement n'ont donc
automatiquement il perd sa fonction de
chef de gouvernement est automatiquement
le chef du groupe parlementaire de
l'opposition devient le chancelier pour
qu'il n'y ait pas une seconde d'absence
de gouvernement parce que à l'époque à
la fin de weimar il y avait comme des
absences d'enfin d incapacité pour le
pour l'assemblée de merci d'avoir une
majorité merci mais non merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'était
vraiment passionnant j'ai rappelé beau
livre très vite on est un peu en retard
ennemi héréditaire un dialogue
franco-allemand pour l'interrogation
bien sûr alors je sais ce que je pouvais
très militaire dont on va voir dialogue
franco-allemand c'est chez fayard marc
lazar les socialistes européens et
l'état je cite celui là aux éditions de
l'aube et patrick martin geniez une
sixième république comment refonder la
démocratie française aux éditions
studyrama